نشرت كتائب القسام رساله لعائلات الاسرى
الاسرائيليين تقول فيها انه اذا استمرت
الحرب فيجب توقع خبر مقتل كل الاسرى لديها
بغارات
الاحتلال في الاثناء قال رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ان مظاهرات
عائلات المخطوفين لا تفيد بل تزيد من
مطالب حماس وتؤخر استعادتهم واضاف نتنياهو
ان هدفه هو القضاء على سلطه حماس وانه لا
يمكن ان يسمح ببقاء قوات مسلحه في غزه وان
الحرب لن تنتهي قبل اكمال المهمه واضاف ان
لدى اسرائيل الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها وان
لا احد بامكانه ان يمنعها من ذلك كما
انتقد نتنياهو الاصوات التي تشكك في
امكانيه تحقيق النصر حسب
تعبيره للاسف هناك بيننا من يشكك في
تصميمنا وقدرتنا على الانتصار هؤلاء
يزرعون الشك اريد ان اقول لكم ايها
المواطنون ان هذه الاصوات تشكل اقليه وهي
اصوات مخطئه ومضلل ونحن رغم كل شيء سننتصر
انتصارا
حاسما هذا وعبرت هيئه عائلات الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في قطاع غزه عن
غضبها بعد خطاب رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو الذي قال فيه ان مظاهرات عائلات
المخطوفين لا تفيد بل تزيد من مطالب حماس
وتؤخر استعادتهم وقالت الهيئه انها تتوقع
من رئيس الوزراء ان يتذكر انه مسؤول منتخب
ووظيفته هي تصحيح الاخفاق وليس توبيخ من
اختطف راد من اسرهم واضافت الهيئه انه اذا
لم تحشد العائلات دعم العالم والشعب
للافراج عن المختطفين فسينتهي بهم الامر
مثل رون اراد الطيار الاسرائيلي المفقود
منذ ثمانينات القرن
الماضي